our mental science and public health it
is profoundly disturbing to see the
actions this EPA has taken to dismantle
many of its own standards and
regulations that were established
primarily to protect public health this
administration's push to deregulate
seems to be led by political ideologies
with limited input from scientific
experts remarkably sometimes this
administration's zeal to rollback public
health protection even exceeds the
desires of industry many members of the
regulated community have come out in
opposition to EPA's recent actions to
roll back regulations on gladder trucks
methane emissions from the oil and gas
industry and EPA's unprecedented and
ill-advised revocation of California's
authority to set its own clean car
standards since the establishment of the
EPA nearly 50 years ago this country has
shown that we can protect everyone from
our most vulnerable populations to our
most healthy without sacrifice and
economic growth but it is naive to think
that because the EPA has been so
successful in accomplishing its mission
over the past decades that we can now
roll back regulations in order to
benefit industry and expect no negative
impacts on public health environment
protections is an ongoing process
it requires the persistence that is
exemplified by the dedicated scientists
and engineers who work at EPA these
committed public servants have the full
support of the American people but they
need your full support mr. administrator
as well as full support of Congress they
helped them to continue to carry out the
agency's mission let me be clear
gutting the roles of science and EPA's
regulatory and decision-making processes
will not
are safer to breathe all right water
safer to drink there's a congressional
committee with jurisdiction over
research and development activities with
EPA my colleagues and I take our
oversight role very seriously we have
attempted to engage with you and your
staff on a number of occasions and
issues that directly impact public
health we are still waiting for adequate
responses from the agency on many of
these inquiries simply stating the total
number of pages of documents provided to
the committee does not address whether
they are responsive to the request I
hope this will not be the only time that
we can see before the committee and
today marks the start of an open
dialogue between our members and
yourself we look forward to working
together with you to ensure that the
best interests of the American public
are at the heart of EPA's actions and
that those actions are informed by the
high caliber science that distinguishes
EPA on the world stage the chair now
recognizes the ranking member mr. Lucas
for a statement
Thank You chairwoman Johnson and Thank
You administrator wheeler for being here
today to discuss the EPA's fiscal year
2020 budget request the EPA is charged
with a broad and vital mission of
protecting our nation's air land and
water from hazardous waste cleanup to
protecting human health to settle
setting clean air and water standards
the EPA's work affects every American
while much of the EPA's regulatory
mission falls under the jurisdiction of
other congressional committees the
Committee on Science Space and
Technology oversees the EPA's work on
environmental research and development
this R D is critical to providing sound
science related related needed for the
EPA to effectively carry out their
mission to protect our environment I'm
looking forward to a discussion about
the role Science and Technology play in
the agency's mission and I'd like to
encourage my colleagues to focus on the
important jurisdiction when questioning
the administrator
in many years on my many years on both
the AG and science committees every
discussion of the EPA included talk of
over-regulation in the past it seemed
like instead of protecting the
environment the EPA was more focused on
pursuing a political agenda that led to
an expansive and I might add expensive
regulatory burdens fortunately this is
no longer the case under the leadership
of administrator wheeler the EPA has
shifted from top-down one-size-fits-all
regulations to a flexible technology
driven approach that works with local
communities to protect our environment
and maintain economic growth I'm
confident that under the leadership of
administrator wheeler America will
remain the gold standard of
environmental protection around the
world and by leveraging new technologies
we can protect our environment without
imposing sweeping government mandates as
the ranking member of the Science
Committee I may be biased but I believe
that technology should be the
cornerstone of our efforts to reduce
global emissions and address our
environmental challenges American
industry is already making great strides
by investing in technologies like carbon
capture advanced nuclear and energy
storage EPA should encourage the
adoption of innovative ways to monitor
and reduce emissions while allowing us
to see use all of our natural resources
safely and effectively this is the kind
of approach that has helped
significantly improve air quality in the
United States according to EPA's most
recent air trends report the number on
unhealthy air days along with the
admissions of key air pollutants have
declined since 2000 our fine particulate
matter levels are five times lower than
the global average and we've made
progress while growing our economy under
the trump administration I've been
pleased to see the EPA focus on using
sound transparent science to develop
environmental solutions that will bring
all the stakeholders to the table if we
want our policies to be successful we
need to be based on the best available
science and also be achievable without
damaging our economy I believe the
administration is working hard on both
I also want to take a moment and applaud
administrator wheeler for finalizing the
first step to repeal the Obama
administration's wotus rule this week
this rule was exactly the wrong way to
protect the environment a federal
government power grab that made it
harder for farmers ranchers and
landowners to do business by returning
to limited regulatory authority
established under the Clean Water Act
the EPA has taken a balanced approach
that's both supports our environment and
our economy but don't let anyone fool
you rolling back this regulation had
nothing to do with ignoring the science
and it won't lead to more pollution in
our waterways in fact the Trump
administration has prioritized efforts
to improve water quality by investing in
water infrastructure although the water
infrastructure finance innovation Act
loan program and the state revolving
funds program the EPA has helped the
local communities modernize outdated
infrastructure and improve water quality
this investment will improve the health
and safety of our nation's waterways and
create jobs I'm sure that we'll hear
criticisms of the EPA today I hope that
instead of falsely attacking the
agency's anti-science or focusing on
administrator wheelers predecessor we
can make this a productive hearing where
we honestly assess the work being done
to protect the environment
I believe the EPA is on the right track
and is working to find a science-based
collaborative approach to ensure all
Americans and future generations we can
enjoy a cleaner safer healthier
environment I want to thank
administrator wheeler again for his hard
work along with all of the staff the EPA
and I look forward to hearing his
testimony this morning and I yield back
madam chair Thank You mr. Lucas if there
are other members who wish to submit
additional opening statements your
statements will be added to the record
at this point
before we open I want to welcome the
moms Clean Air Force in the audience and
red t-shirts parents united against air
pollution thank you for coming at this
time I'd like to introduce our witness
the Honorable Andrew wheeler currently
serves as
15th administrator of the Environmental
Protection Agency mr. Wheeler has spent
his career working on environmental
topics started his career as a special
assistant to the EPA's pollution
prevention and toxics office under the
HW Bush administration he spent 12 years
on the Senate committee of environmental
Public Works serving six of those years
as chief counsel and minority and
majority staff director in 2009 mr. will
is shifted to private sector work and
was a principal and team leader of the
energy and environment practice group as
well as co-chair of the Energy and
Natural Resources Group at the friggin
maker Daniels consulting he was
nominated to serve as the deputy
administrator of EPA in October 2000
2017 and was confirmed as administrator
in February 2019 he earned his law
degree at Washington University in st.
Louis and his MBA at George Mason
University
he's also an Eagle Scout administrator
wheeler you will have five minutes for
your spoken testimony your written
testimony will be included in the record
for the hearing when you have completed
your spoken testimony we'll begin around
the questions each member will have four
minutes to questions in the panel
welcome you may begin your testimony
good morning and thank you chair Roman
Johnson for the introduction and I do
agree I hope today's hearing is the
start of a good open dialogue with the
committee between myself and the
committee and my staff thank you very
much
good morning ranking member Lucas and
members of the committee the
Environmental Protection Agency is one
of the world's leading research
organizations every day our scientists
and researchers develop information and
technology that are critical to
protecting human health in the
environment since I've taken the lead at
EPA I visited five of our research
facilities and the lake Guardian our
largest research vessel located on the
Great Lakes I'm rarely briefed by agency
scientists and I rely on their work an
expert
I'm always impressed with the rigor
integrity and dedication of our career
scientists and staff I'm here today to
discuss the ways that we are supporting
and advancing their efforts we are
promoting science of the agency more
than it has been in years and these
efforts are leading to groundbreaking
advancements in environmental science
earlier this week for example we
announced approximately six million
dollars in new funding to eight leading
research organizations to advance our
understanding of PFS this is just one of
the many ways that we are delivering on
our PFS action plan the most
comprehensive multimedia research and
risk communication plan to address a
chemical of concern ever issued by the
epa our scientists working in concert
with the Department of Defense are
providing the research and technology to
support the action plan they're
developing methods to detect and
quantify pea fasts and the air water and
soil they are evaluating methods to
treat or remove pea fast from drinking
water they developed a draft toxicity
assessment for Gen X and P FBS and they
are working to understand the potential
toxicity for the many other PFS and
their potential degradation products EPA
is one of the few places in the world
where this type of cutting-edge science
is being conducted to day in and day out
we're also leading the way on research
for reducing childhood lead exposure our
scientists are defying high risk areas
and providing technical assistance for
reducing lead in drinking water and a
contaminated sites they're modeling
efforts and research activities are
directly impacting major regulatory
decisions such as our forthcoming
proposal to update the lead and copper
rule the first major update in over two
decades and the same outstanding
researchers who provided vital
information
it's how Flint Michigan are now working
with state and local officials in Newark
New Jersey on their efforts to ensure
safe drinking water for the city's
residents to support our scientists and
researchers we are continuing looking
for ways to make the agency more
effective and more responsive that is
why we are restructuring the office of
research and development we've briefed
many of you and your staff on this
reorganization
but I like to reiterate that it will
help ordy better address the
increasingly complex environmental
challenges of the 21st century it will
not result in the loss of jobs it does
not change any of the important work or
D is tasked with only how we manage
those functions now let's remind you
that this effort was led by EPA career
staff we plan to have the reorganization
in place by October 1st earlier this
month we took another step in
modernizing the agency by committing to
aggressively reduce animal testing this
issue is very important to me personally
advances in computer modeling and env
protesting are surpassing animal testing
and we need to keep pace I issued a memo
that commits the agency to important
goals such as reducing mammal study
requests and funding by 30 percent by
2025 and then eliminating all requests
and funding by 2035 any requests for
funding after 2035 will require the
administrators approval on a
case-by-case basis
we also announced four and a quarter
million dollars in funding to five
research universities to advance the
development of alternative test methods
for evaluating the safety of chemicals
that will minimize and hopefully
eliminate the need for animal testing
finally we are committed to the highest
quality science good science is science
that can be replicated and independently
validated science that holds up to
scrutiny that is why we're moving
forward to ensure that the science
supporting agency decisions is
transparent and available for evaluation
by the public and stakeholders I cut my
teeth as a career employee at the agency
working on the Community right-to-know
Act I fundamentally believe the more
information we provide to the public the
better our regulations will be and the
more they will trust our decisions at
the same time we will ensure that we're
not disclosing confidential or personal
information other agencies already do
that and we can do the same our proposed
rule will apply prospectively to final
significant regulatory actions and we
intend to issue a supplemental proposed
rule for a science transparency
regulation early next year I'm very
proud of the science we do at the agency
as you all heard at a recent hearing EPA
has one of the strongest scientific
integrity policies and the federal
government
the GAO report recently examined our
policies and those of nine other
agencies and we are the only agency that
is that received no recommendations to
correct deficiencies that is a testament
to the tremendous work of the EPA career
staff I will continue to support them in
their work and we will ensure that the
EPA of the 21st century remains a global
leader in science and research thank you
thank you mr. Whelan I'd like to ask now
unanimous consent that representative
axe needn't be allowed to join us on the
dais and then further I'd like to
acknowledge and recognize mr. Tonko for
the first round of questions as he has
to leave thank you very much madam chair
I appreciate your flexibility and
welcome mr. administrator EPA
established its scientific integrity
policy in 2012 in order to formalize the
agency's approach to honesty
communication professional development
and expert engagement on scientific
issues as you likely know the Government
Accountability Office is review of
scientific integrity policies at several
federal agencies highlighted the EPA's
robust scientific integrity policies I
would like to congratulate the EPA for
its impressive scientific integrity
policy particularly as I work to pass
the scientific integrity Act which would
codify standardized and strengthened
scientific integrity policies across our
federal agencies I just heard your
closing statement but I want to ask
again until we can codify this
requirement can I expect your continued
support for your agency's robust
scientific integrity policies yes
absolutely thank you sir
and chlorpyrifos is a pesticide that
causes severe short and long-term health
impacts agricultural workers have
collapsed from exposure nauseated and
convulsing particularly horrifying are
the impacts of chlorpyrifos on
developing fetuses and young children
when EPA proposed in 2015 to ban the
chemical his cited studies showing that
at three years old the likelihood of
highly exposed children developing
mental delays were significantly greater
than those with lower prenatal exposure
but just this past July EPA announced it
would allow chlorpyrifos back on the
market I have a series of
I would asks you respond to in yes-or-no
fashion in rolling back EPA's
recommended ban on Corp glorp arrow foes
did the agency consider its own findings
about the severe health and
developmental consequences for children
and workers exposed to this specialized
pesticide sir yes or no our career staff
looked aggressively at the science that
we had that's yes APA previously stated
that the agency's assessment contains
sufficient evidence to conclude that
negative neurodevelopmental effects from
chlorpyrifos occur at exposure levels
below the currently permitted level are
you aware of the yes or no of the
findings in this report the EPA's
revised human health risk assessment I'm
aware of those but we are currently
reviewing though the the the pesticide
that's not reviewed by 2022 thank you
did EPA base its decision to allow
industrial use of chlorpyrifos on new
unrevealed scientific evidence that
contradicted or discredited the agency's
2015 analysis yes or no I would have to
get back to you on that because I wanna
make sure i dont miss state on the
science that the career scientists used
for that decision please do so in in
rapid fashion did this specifically
include the evidence of chlorpyrifos
impairing the brain development of
children and fetuses yes or no I can't
comment on the specific studies of this
career scientists used for their
determination I would want to I don't
want to miss speak well these are
important I insist they're in SiteWatch
the regulations for my career scientists
on Corp IRA Fossen they've recommended
that we continue with it they undergo
the the longer review thank you sir I
just want to use my time here in 2017
your predecessor Scott Pruett announced
that EPA would delay the 2015 proposed
ban on chlorpyrifos citing regulatory
certainty for our industry as his reason
mr. wheeler can you remind me the stated
mission of EPA our mission is to protect
public health in the environment thank
you sir
is there anywhere the federal
insecticide fungicide rodent aside act
fora where a regulatory certainty for
industry is named as an evaluation
criteria for EPA's decision making
we try to provide regulatory certainty
for everything that we do certainty for
the American public certainty for them
for the community yes or no nothing
specifically in that statue but we Pro
we tried to provide regulatory certainty
for all of our decisions and we try to
make all of our decisions open and
transparent for everybody to see what am
i selling that's a no I have to go back
to remember what the wording of your
exact question law is there anything
with in FIFRA where regulatory certainty
for industry is named as an evaluation
criteria where of now so it's a no with
that madam chair I yield back
thank you very much mr. Lucas thank you
madam chair
I expect the theme of this hearing to be
climate change with particular criticism
aimed at the president's decision to
draw from the Paris climate Court my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle seem to believe that with that
international agreements burdensome
regulations or trillions of dollars
spent on the green New Deal it's
impossible to protect the environment
but as I said in my opening statement
data tells us another story
the United States is Slee a leader in
reducing emissions yet we remain one of
the War of the largest economies the
world illustrator wheeler can you
provide the committee with the progress
the EPA is made to date and cleaning up
air water and land and what steps you
plan to take to keep America as the gold
standard of Environmental Protection
around the world absolutely we are the
gold standard everybody else in the
world looks to us on we the EPA measures
six criteria air pollutants we've done
that since 1970 those six criteria air
pollutants have been reduced
seventy-four percent since 1970 our air
is seventy four percent cleaner all six
of the criteria air pollutants have been
reduced during the Trump administration
in 1970 again at that time on the water
side 40 percent of our water sources did
not meet EPA's standards on a day to day
basis
today over 90 percent of our water
supply meets the EPA standards every
single day that doesn't mean to say that
the remaining don't meet the standards
but they occasionally may have a blip
because of a contaminant but we work
with us
and local governments to make sure that
those are very small short lasting and
that we get back to having clean safe
drinking water for everyone across the
country administrator do you believe
that we need a heavy-handed top-down
approach to environmental regulation or
based on the EPA's analysis can a more
flexible state-led program be just as
effective in the long run it can be and
we were working more more cooperatively
with the states than the previous
administration at the the Obama
administration on the air side issued 10
times as many federal implementation
plans instead of state implementation
plans as the three administration's
previous combined we have been turning
those fits and two sips on the average
of one per month we also inherited 700
sip backlog we've already reduced that
backlog by 400 so we are working
cooperatively with the states to make
sure that they are protecting the
environment of their residents
administrator what about incorporating
new technology I've heard from my
constituents that it can be difficult to
demonstrate new technologies for
admission admissions control emissions
control or monitoring to meet regulatory
standards have you considered new ways
to encourage the adoption of innovative
technology solutions in your regulatory
approach yes and that's part of what we
based for our decision on methane we
want to make sure that we're not
stifling technological developments in
that industry our on natural gas methane
is natural gas natural gas has doubled
in production since 1990 at the same
time the industry has reduced their
methane emissions 15% we want to make
sure that we don't go forward with a
regulation that is going to stifle
innovative technologies that are that
are capturing the methane emissions and
making sure that we don't have those
emissions Thank You administrator yield
back the balance of my time madam chair
thank you very much miss Laughlin thank
you mr. wheeler in June you wrote to
Congress that Mary Nichols of the
California Air Resources Board was not
negotiating in good faith with the EPA
to reach a compromise on vehicle fuel
emission and tailpipe standards in that
she was lying
when she told members of Congress in the
Energy and Commerce Committee that she'd
made a sincere counter proposal but it's
my understanding that the counteroffer
that the CA r be made is essentially the
voluntary agreement that was reached
with the automakers earlier this year
announced on July 25th so it sounds to
me like ms Nichols was telling the truth
to the Energy and Commerce Committee and
I would like to ask unanimous consent
madam chairperson to put into the record
an article from the LA Times about this
issue mr. wheeler would you be willing
to share the briefing materials prepared
by EPA staff that analyzed California's
offer to EPA would you be willing to
share that with this committee I have to
certainly share what we can with the
committee there may be deliberative
documents involved in that but I want to
just make sure you understand the offer
that Mary Nichols gave us last fall she
said at the time that although she was
putting on the table she said that the
outgoing governor did not sign off on it
the incoming governor didn't sign off on
it the Attorney General already
threatened to sue us didn't sign on we
are going to sue you her board did not
members of her board hadn't signed off
on it and she also said that if I may my
time is limited because what she offered
is what the deal they basically made
with the auto and at the same day that
they did that the Department of
Transportation indicated that the
administration did not prevent
manufacturers and building more
efficient vehicles on a voluntary basis
if they wanted to so I think the threats
that are being made by the
administration are really contradicted
by the Department of Transportation
comment at that time I'd like to also
note that senator Feinstein has sent a
letter to the Attorney General
pointing out that the I really think
it's it's an abuse of power on the part
of the Department of Justice to try and
threaten automakers who are reaching an
agreement with the state I
and to to deter other automakers from
entering the same deal but they're not
disagreeing that with the other deals
that are being made for example
rear-seat reminder systems that are
being made and that's not being
challenged as an antitrust violation so
I just want to say express my concern
not only about the decision being that
was made here I mean we California had
more than a hundred waivers in the last
50 years by both Democratic and
Republican presidents and to achieve a
standard that has made automobiles 99%
cleaner than they would have been
otherwise the the lawsuit that is going
to be engaged in is going to you created
chaos here because the automakers are
not going to know what to do this is
going to be tied up in court for the
foreseeable future and I would hope that
you would take a look at the the chaos
that has been created for clean air but
also in the auto industry by the actions
that have been taken that are really
unprecedented in the history of the
Clean Air Act and with that madam chair
I I it's it's important to remember that
we're doing nothing to take away
California's ability to set health base
standards for automobiles only energy
efficiency thank you very much a mr.
Webber
thank mention mr. Feder wheeler I'm
extremely interested in that last
exchange regarding Mary Nichols you were
enumerated everybody that basically
hadn't signed off would you go back to
that listing and explain why that was
what she put on the table was basically
the Obama plan spaced out over one
additional year and she said that
although she's printed on the table for
us that the outgoing governor and this
was right around the election last year
for the in California the Ocwen governor
had not signed off on it the incoming
governor hadn't signed off on it the
Attorney General who already said he was
suing us and not signed off on the deal
and she is the executive director of
carbs
she said that the board members of carb
had not signed off on it so it you know
really wasn't a a deal it wasn't really
an offer that she could stand behind or
that she had any authority apparently to
make to us I'd also point out that the
the deal that the congresswoman
mentioned with the four automakers we
haven't seen the specifics of that deal
nothing has been released to the public
so I don't know if it's the same as what
as what the carb executive director put
on the table last fall I don't know if
it's the same deal or not so you would
say that's a pretty good example of not
negotiating in good faith yes I would I
would agree with that
all I want to Segway and ask are the
administrator we are the comprehensive
regulatory reforms you person are
undertaking the EPA which we appreciate
including policies
you
by any change of any views on air and
water science or are they instead driven
by an effort to restore the statutory
authority provided at the EPA via the
Clean Air Act the Clean Water Act as
well as other statutes
both we certainly use science and all of
our regulatory decisions but you're
right on the on the ACE rule it replaced
the clean power plan but the clean power
plan never took effect because the
Supreme Court issued an historic stay
which show that it was outside of the
bounds of the Clean Air Act on wotus as
soon as the Obama administration went
forward with their waters proposal it
was it was stayed by courts around the
country it was only in effect in 22
states 28 other states we're not
following the Obama what is proposed
Allah had to withdrawal it so that we
could have one regulation for the entire
country we didn't think a patchwork
approach would be useful for what is
well we in Texas particularly in my
district appreciate that we really do
despite the overall decline in the
number of unhealthy air days since 2000
there was an uptick in the number of bad
air days in some parts of the country
last year is this because the EPA is
rolling back environmental protections
or how do natural events dust storms
wildfires variations in weather effect
and in air quality concentration affect
air quality concentrations from year to
year how does that happen it's both
first of all you know since since 2000
we have strengthened the regulations so
you know that the regulatory
determinations are tighter than they
were plus there are a lot of naturally
occurring events around the country that
contribute to bad air quality I was in
Alaska
last month and was saw the smoke from
the fires firsthand outside of Anchorage
there the with the wildfires in
California that contributes
significantly the poor air quality days
across the West other fires do the same
thing when this is why I really hope
that the the Forest Service and working
with the states can get a handle on
these out-of-control wildfires have more
prescribed burns try to clear out the
underbrush so that we don't
these long lasting fires that really are
detrimental to public health well I
appreciate that mr. Minnis traitor and
madam chair uh thank you I'm going to
yield back
thank you very much let me welcome an
additional attendance of members of the
Clean Air Force welcome mr. Lipinski
thank you madam chair
administrator wheeler 2016 researchers
in the EPA's office of research and
development updated the integrated risk
information system or iris value for
ethylene oxide which is known as H eto
in doing so they determines that cancer
risk for inhalation of eto was 30 times
higher than previously thought
in August 20 18 EPA scientists release
the latest version of the National air
toxics assessment based on the new iris
value this revealed an elevated
cancerous in the communities around a
commercial sterilization facility in
Willowbrook just outside my district
facility owned by stereo genex I not
only represent families in the impacted
communities I also live there thanks to
the state of Illinois this plant is now
closed perhaps only temporarily
I've been calling on the EPA to act
quickly to protect not only the families
in these communities around Sturridge
annex but those around eto so is that
use eto for sterilization all around the
country we need the EPA to use the
updated iris value for eto to set a
strong new federal emission standard
that protects Americans all across our
country from this dangerous carcinogen I
first wrote to you then Acting
Administrator on September 21st 2018
almost exactly one year ago when will
the EPA set a new standard for eto to
protect Americans all across our country
we are working on two different rule
makings to address eto and both of those
are in the works but we have been
working hand-in-hand with both the local
government as well as the state
it was APA that provided the monitors
the ambient air monitors the modeling to
determine what the impact was from
Willowbrook we worked with the state
they used our data to make the
determinations that they did on that
facility and we worked with the facility
to and to make sure that they were
installing better technologies to
capture the emissions so that it does
not get into the the neighborhood there
there are a lot of issues around eto
well I want to make sure that are you
going to use the updated iris values
iris according to the EPA's website says
iris assessments as a preferred source
of toxicity information used by the EPA
and I want to make sure that you're
committed to using this updated iris
value for the cancer risk for eto when
developing at this new standard are you
committed to that we are using the iris
assessment and for our regulatory
decisions it's important to remember
that the iris program is not a
regulatory program so we also have to
make sure that we are following the
regulatory requirements of the statutes
this is the Clean Air Act that we are
using to set the standards for that
facility for each I just want to make
sure that you're gonna use use it
because there's been some arguments
against it and I it's critical that that
science is not ignored we use all of our
available science for making regulatory
decisions but again the iris program is
not a regulatory program well I want to
close by reiterating a request from my
neighbors in Illinois who would
appreciate your participation in October
second town hall on ethylene oxide in
Lake County I firmly expect the EPA to
do its job engaging with the public at
this event
I appreciate the air monitoring around
the facility in Willowbrook but is
important that EPA set a standard to
protect Americans from this dangerous
cancer-causing chemical and EPA needs to
us EPA needs to act quickly and
decisively on this issue thank you Thank
You mr. congressman and I I know you're
also concerned about the Great Lakes um
last month we announced first-ever trash
free Great Lakes grant program to help
get the Great Lake
cleaned up Thank You mr. babban thank
you very much madam chair administrator
wheeler thank you for being here a few
weeks ago you commented on an often
overlooked provision of the Clean Air
Act section 115 an integral part of
President Trump's decision to pull the
United States out of the Paris climate
agreement you said another aspect that a
lot of people gloss over is that under
the Clean Air Act if we enter into an
international treaty such as the Paris
climate Accord if we fail to meet our
targets those are enforceable under our
domestic laws while this issue gets very
little attention this seems like a very
big deal to me for example we know that
advisors to Hillary Clinton's
presidential campaign supported invoking
section 115 but recommended against
mentioning it during the campaign
because I imagine they thought that
using an obscure provision regulate the
entire US economy would not poll very
well I would like to enter into the
record an article written by the Center
for American Progress titled how the
Paris agreement supercharges the Clean
Air Act madam chair without objection
thank you that which details exactly how
far those on the far left would use
Paris to impose overreaching climate
regulations across the US economy can
you please elaborate on this threat from
section 115 and how it might be used to
circumvent the US Congress certainly I'm
first I do want to just clarify my
remarks from a few weeks ago I didn't
mean to suggest that that was one of the
primary reasons President Trump used for
withdrawing from the Paris climate
Accord I actually wasn't with the
administration at the time so I did not
brief I did not brief the President on
the Paris climate Accord I know he cited
trade issues right was the fact that we
were treated differently from China and
India and other countries but I
completely agree with you that section
115 could I'm give and I think that the
Center for American Progress our paper
on this is evidence of that that there
are certainly people that want to use
that section of the Clean Air Act to
to allow third parties to sue the United
States government if they fail to meet
treaty obligations and force them to
then meet the treaty obligations and the
Paris and the Paris climate Accord